today's topic yes this is another
youtuber named kai sinash there's a
video in particular that someone sent me
they said you should check this out so
we are going to um we're going to take a
look today bro
adam sandler
no
peter parker sorry toby mcguire
justin timberlake
some some cats from fritos and sign a
drink
[Music]
this what you mean
you taking it out of this yeah out of my
mind
[Music]
that's your money
wait i can't pay for it though
uh i'm just playing with y'all i'm gonna
go ahead and tip y'all my fault i'm just
playing with y'all
not
i was just playing with y'all so yeah i
don't want the tip
[Music]
it was all for play i was just joking
huh
you don't want my money
damn i'm thinking
i can't tip nobody just to
i ain't mean no harm bro
you say what
it's not that serious bro what am i
doing wrong okay [ __ ] take their job
way too soon well ain't no way bro
there's literally no way he he he the
[ __ ] want to fight me over getting
tipped 20 20
damn am i being a menace right now i
don't know keep it a stack i don't think
so cause it's like you're not taking it
i'm not taking it you're giving them you
feel me no am i doing something wrong
right now because somebody please tell
me that i just feel like people nowadays
take their job way too serious and
sometimes i just need some laughter and
like feel what i'm saying
tell me to go you oh please go
maybe
maybe it's because you're a youtuber
maybe you
have never had to have your own place
and struggle to make rent and work a
[ __ ] job every day
maybe
maybe you haven't had to wake up and hit
your [ __ ] day before it even started
maybe
you haven't been spat on by a customer
yup
maybe you haven't had customers come on
and look down on you and you have to
smile on them because it's customer
service all to make seven eight bucks an
hour
you gotta work slave wages just to make
rent
and guess what
sometimes
a customer is aggressive enough to leave
a couple quarters in the tip jar and at
the end of the day maybe you guys get
twenty dollars in that whole tip jar and
you split it four ways an extra five
dollars it ain't much but maybe you get
to treat yourself after work the tip jar
is sometimes the only bonus you get
and some random customer comes in
grabs the one bright spot that you have
at your workplace throughout the day and
[ __ ] with it
and looks you in the eyes like you're
the stupid one
and [ __ ] with your emotion and gets you
heated because like am i gonna have to
fight somebody because they're trying to
steal money i earned
you dragged the joke on for a while
getting them all riled up
and then when your shitty ass joke
doesn't translate you want to say
it's just a joke
[ __ ] i'm already heated
i'm already heated you already [ __ ] up
my day
and you want to try to buy me off
afterwards like my emotions are only
worth twenty dollars
again
maybe this man is just so disconnected
and his cameraman is clearly a yes man
who also lacks self-awareness always
never have to work a minimum wage job
because y'all acting a fool
people struggle
life is not easy not everyone puts up my
videos and makes money from adsense
[ __ ] is really struggling out
here
and you want to come and just [ __ ] with
their emotions and offer them twenty
dollars as consolation
and then record them
without their consent
you went into a private business and
recorded employees let me tell you that
can get your videos taken off youtube
yes you need to sign waiver forms
because they're not in public
so here you have these people again all
riled up you film them without them
knowing you put it online for you to
make money and then afterwards you have
the audacity to act like you're doing
them a favor
what if that 20 is not enough for them
to want to be online
huh
clout is a hell of a drunk
people want to be on youtube and make
money
and they don't really care how they do
it
but i would ask you
to be more considerate of the people
that you're pranking how you doing can i
have a caramel uh mick frappe it's five
dollars
i thought it was like two something
all right damn boy
i might as well
stop
what are you doing
i'm paying paying the [ __ ] i gotta put
this back
i thought oh okay okay i didn't i didn't
know you had another chip draw over here
i thought so you said [ __ ]
what you trying to get
the frappe
i can't really hear you because of the
mask
bro what you trying to guess
what a long day
yo yo yo
yo
thank you
like hey people people ain't got time
for this [ __ ] there's hard-working
people out there just trying to make a
living maybe it's just the grown ass man
in me talking
i'm not about that i'm not
i thought i could pay with the tip i'll
just count up the five dollars right
here
why she ain't got yes girl
yes
that's my girl right there she said
things she's like listen
put that back
you know whenever you work in service
everybody that worked at service had
that one day if someone coming
with me today
i'ma [ __ ] you up
i do appreciate it when someone's acting
a fool and your boss got your back oh
and they laid down the law you like [ __ ]
i like working for this [ __ ]
when your boss got your back like that
he's like yo what you want yeah you want
me to make a double you want me to do a
double today sorry i need you to leave
the premises right now yo
get this i'm in the back in my
head get that [ __ ] get out of here
i'll be like
customer service says i got to be like
this
but in my head
[Music]
you need to leave the premises son bro
what are you doing are you not allowed
to play with tips
okay if you think how high it's funny
man i need you to put it back no i'm not
trying to be funny i'm i'm so serious
right now
you dragged this joke out way longer
than you should have you gave them the
punch line already
they've been over it they know you
playing now they just want to move on
with a day and you still going
by this point i want him to get snuffed
i want someone to go out around the
counter and yank it's not that i want
that to happen but if it happens to me
to me
okay if that happens if someone comes
out of there and just you know one two
one two three
two
or something that happened
you know what it would have been fun if
you really can't
when the audience is helping you with
how to organize your joke you know your
joke and your prank is trash
they're like listen it might have been
funny if you're like yo can i have this
if you're in the middle of a show listen
i'm just telling you this okay i've had
this happen before it opened mike's
where [ __ ] delivers a punchline and
some of the crowds like
yeah
you kind of messed up the punch line if
you organize it but i'm like damn [ __ ]
you're saying it's going so bad [ __ ] is
giving you constructive criticism at
this point we got simon
they're not even heckling no they're
giving you because they feel sorry for
you because they feel sorry you know you
really want
put the mic back
and go think about your try it again but
with more energy it's like whoa
all right i'll take at least a dollar
the 39 cents at least
the 39 cents at least please please
i need it i need it i'm just playing
around with you
i just
yeah i'm recording right there
i just drunk of a child
either
[Music]
i apologize if i'm any harm
all right you guys too some people would
like to take their job way too serious
i took them 20. nobody google tip i'm
20. i took starbucks 40 they was still
mad i took them 20. they're still mad
i know like you said earlier maybe i'm
getting old
maybe but you know what i try to wake up
every day and try not to piss people off
and get in their way i try
you know what i think a lot of us can do
well in this world by trying not to get
in each other's way and you'd already
make the world a much better place
but anyways
gonna tell you this so far
i'm gonna talk to you dude
you're doing this youtube [ __ ] you have
to know that this is a privilege we're
in a place of privilege right now
yeah
we're privileged
all these [ __ ] as you're
antagonizing have masking their faces
they lost their jobs at some point
trying to work hard this is not easy
what you're doing
you're living your privilege
that's a privilege to be there
i got a bunch of my friend comedians
they're not doing what i'm doing
they don't have that privilege
and they've been suffering what we do
here
is privilege
be careful how you use that privilege
bro everything that happened said he
said
i agree with it
all this [ __ ] that we doing
is extra don't [ __ ] with people's day
don't [ __ ] with people's family
don't [ __ ] with people's food
don't [ __ ] with people's money
even if you didn't have the intent of
taking it or whatever what not don't
[ __ ] with it
it's not even the joke i understand the
joke
i understand that was a joke
you dragged it you [ __ ] the whole mood
up and i believe that everything that
you said after was a is an act it's an
old ad you're acting that you know
exactly you know damn well
what you're doing
you want people to react
and you know what
you're doing a good job
you got our attention
which actually makes it worse
because you're not crazy you don't have
a deficiency you're not you know what
you're doing it makes it worse
someone that doesn't have the
self-awareness or whatever they don't
you know damn well what you're doing
the afterthought i don't know i gave
them you know what you're doing you know
you know what you're doing that's worse
than not knowing
you're plain dumb you're being a [ __ ]
right now stop all right if you get
snuffed you get what you get what were
you saying
i don't even think he knows i genuinely
believe that this man like you want to
know why he said a comment i thought was
interesting he said actually that man
twenty dollars and he didn't want the
tip but you know damn well if i would
try to give that man a thousand dollars
he would have been fine with it in his
head he truly believes that money can
smooth over anything because generally
what he's seen online and what he's seen
other youtubers do is like they give a
prize no matter how [ __ ] up a lot of
these young guys because he's a young
man
they watch this content online of these
people doing these pranks and then they
see them smooth it over with money or
it's just a prank and they really think
it's okay it's why [ __ ] go up to
people and pull out knives and go it's
just a prank this is a prank they don't
understand
social cues
they just see stuff on youtube and
replicate it
and really think everything's kosher not
knowing that there's real people on the
other end of those pranks who have
suffered in their day-to-day lives and
they don't know what they've been
through it's this
i'm gonna use you to make content but i
don't know who you are so when i put you
in front of the camera let's see what
happens
that's the way they're going at it
you understand what i'm saying
i firmly believe because me watching
that whole video it didn't strike me
that he had any self-awareness did it to
you
he couldn't tell when his jokes were
terrible he couldn't tell when he was
dragging on the joke for too long and he
seemed genuinely surprised by people
being really upset at his joke i'm not
he expected the initial when the dude
didn't want it and he wanted to fight
him he seemed actually like yo what the
[ __ ] i just think this is a young man
who don't know better
listen
go for it
i had
very bad days at jobs i had in the past
very bad days
very very bad days yeah
and there were some times that i was in
a very bad
mental state
very bad
that was prequel then
10 years ago
you would have tried me there
it's dangerous bro
now on top of that with kobe
bruh
i was not well
just trying to make ends meet
not being happy bro
you want to [ __ ] with that
go ahead
what's gonna happen to you is gonna
happen to you
and i'm gonna nobody's gonna feel sorry
about it
nobody
just try to walk the world not trying to
piss people off
now you're getting out of your way to
and sometimes you're going to do some
things
[ __ ] up that even sorry is not going
to be able to redeem stuff they don't
have to accept your apology
yeah so that's that but it's good
content
it's great content it's like those dudes
who did that prank up in i think it's
new jersey or something they went up to
these guys in a parking lot pulled out a
knife and then somebody shot at them
and the cops said yeah that's not an
issue you can shoot at them so the
prankster dies
but yeah yeah you're defending yourself
listen i don't know i don't know it's a
prank i see someone coming at me with a
knife and i got a gun
i don't i feel like one of the main
themes of this video is accountability
and don't [ __ ] with people
don't start some [ __ ] and there won't be
some [ __ ]
right
i don't prank [ __ ] i don't
prank hey listen man just just be
mindful you know young lovely listen i'm
not even trying to come down on you to
be like you can't nothing like that i
just want you to be more mindful of the
people that you're using to make content
making money is great fantastic get your
bread but be considered the people that
you make bread off of they matter their
mental state matters and if you have no
compassion for that if you don't take
that into consideration and if you have
audacity afterwards to shame them and be
like why the [ __ ] do these people take
their job so seriously because it's how
they get to eat at the end of the day
you got probably enough money to keep
you going for a long time if you want to
[ __ ] are living paycheck to
paycheck with debt and their name
it's hard out here they got kids they
got to take care of family members
school they want to go to they have no
idea they're going to pay their bills
and you come and [ __ ] with them you need
to be more respectful then okay so do
content keep making bread keep growing
your brain good for you but i just ask
you to be more mindful of people who are
struggling okay that's so anyways that's
what i want to say let us know what you
guys think in the comments below we want
to hear from you